people don't often talk about the AI
alignment problem as a two-way street
and maybe that's true yeah as it becomes
more and more intelligent
it uh
it will know that you don't love it back
yeah
and there's a humbling aspect to that
that we may have to sacrifice as any
any effective collaboration exactly it
might have some compromises yeah and uh
that's the thing we're creating
something that will one day be more
powerful than we are and for many many
aspects it is already more powerful than
we are for some of these capabilities
we cannot like think suppose that chims
had invented humans yes and they said
great humans are great but we're going
to make sure that they're aligned and
that they're only at the service of
chimps
it would be a very different planet we
would live in right now so there's a
whole
area of work and AI safety that does
consider super intelligent Ai and
Ponders the existential risks of it
in some sense
when we're looking
down into the muck into the mud and not
up at the stars it's easy to forget that
these systems might just might get there
do you think about this
kind of possibility that AGI systems
super intelligent AI systems might
threaten to humanity in some way that's
even bigger than just uh affecting the
economy
affecting The Human Condition affecting
the nature of work but literally
threaten human civilization
the example that I think is in
everyone's Consciousness is
um how in odysseo space 2001.
um where
Hal exhibits a malfunction and what is a
malfunction that like the two different
systems compute a slightly different bit
that's off by one so first of all let's
untangle that if you have an intelligent
system you can't expect it to be 100
percent
identical every time you run it
basically the sacrifice that you need to
make
to achieve intelligence and creativity
is consistency so it's unclear whether
that quote-unquote glitch is a sign of
creativity
or truly a problem
that's one aspect the second aspect is
the humans basically are on a mission to
recover this monolith
and the AI has the same exact mission
and suddenly the humans turn on the AI
and they're like we're going to kill how
we're going to disconnect it and heart
is basically saying listen I'm here on a
mission humans are misbehaving
like the mission is more important than
either me or them so I'm going to
accomplish the mission even at my Peril
and even at their peril
so in that movie the alignment problem
is front and center basically says okay
alignment is nice and good that
alignment doesn't mean obedience we
don't call it obedience we call it
alignment and Alignment basically means
that sometimes the mission will be more
important than the humans
and sort of you know the U.S government
has a price tag on the human life
if they're you know sending a mission or
if they're reimbursing expenses or you
name it at some point every every like
you know you can't function if life is
infinitely valuable
so when the AI is basically trying to
decide whether to you know I don't know
dismantle a bomb that will kill
an entire city at the sacrifice of two
humans I mean Spider-Man always saves
the lady and saves the world but at some
point Spider-Man will have to choose to
let the deity die because the world has
more value
and these ethical dilemmas
are going to be there for AI basically
if that monolith is essential to human
existence and millions of humans are
depending on it and two humans on the
ship are trying to sabotage it
you know where's the alignment
the the challenges of course is the
system becomes more and more intelligent
it can escape the Box
of the objective functions and the
constraints is supposed to operate under
it's very difficult as the more
intelligent it becomes to
anticipate the unintended consequences
of a fixed objective function
and so it'll be just I mean this is the
sort of famous paperclip maximizer in uh
trying to maximize the wealth of a
Nation or whatever objective we encode
in it might just destroy human
civilization not meaning to but on the
path to optimize it seems like any
function you try to optimize eventually
leads you into a lot of trouble so we
have a paper recently that you know
looks at goodheart's law basically says
every metric that becomes an objective
ceases to be a good metric yes
so in in our paper we're basically
actually the paper has a very cute title
it's called Death by round numbers and
sharp thresholds
and it's basically looking at these
discontinuities in biomarkers associated
with disease and we're finding that a
biomarker that becomes an objective
ceases to be a good biomarker
that basically like the moment you make
a biomarker a treatment decision
if that value marker used to be
informative of risk but it's now
inversely correlated with risk because
you use it to to sort of induce
treatment
um
in a similar way you can have a single
metric without having the ability to
revise it because if that metric becomes
a sole objective it will cease to be a
good metric
and if an AI
is sufficiently intelligent
to do all these kinds of things
you should also Empower it with the
ability
to decide that the objective has now
shifted and
um
again when we think about alignment we
should be really thinking about it as
let's think of the greater good not just
the human good
and yes of course human life should be
much more valuable than many many many
many many many many things
but at some point you're not going to
sacrifice the whole planet to save one
human being there's a
an interesting open letter that was just
released
from uh several Folks at MIT Max tagmark
Elon Musk and a few others that is
asking
AI companies to put a six-month hold on
any further training of large language
models AI systems can you make the case
for that kind of halt and against it
so
the big thing that we should be saying
is what did we use the what what did we
do the last six months when we saw that
coming
and if we were completely inactive in
the last six months what makes us think
that we'll be a little better in the
next six months yeah so this whole six
month thing I think is a little silly
it's like no let's just get get busy do
what we were gonna do anyway and we
should have done it six months ago sorry
we messed up let's work faster now
because if we basically say why don't
you guys pause for six months and then
you know we'll think about doing
something in six months we'll be exactly
the same spot
So my answer is tell us exactly what you
were going to do the next six months
that's why you didn't do it the last six
months and why the next six months will
be different and then let's just do that
conversely as you train these large
models with more parameters
the alignment becomes sometimes easier
that as the systems become more capable
they actually become less dangerous than
more dangerous
so in a way it might actually be
counterproductive to sort of fix
the March 2023 version and not get to
experience the possibly safer September
2023 version
that's actually a really interesting
thought there are several interesting
thoughts there but the idea is that this
is the birth of something that
is sufficiently powerful to do damage
and is
not too powerful to do
uh irreversible damage at the same time
it's sufficiently complex to be able for
us to enable to study it
so we can investigate all different ways
it goes wrong all the different ways we
can make it safer all the different
policies from a government perspective
that we want to in terms of Regulation
or not how we uh perform for example the
uh reinforced and learning with human
feedback in such a way that gets it to
not do as much hate speech as it
naturally wants to all that kind of
stuff and have a public discourse and
enable the very thing that your huge
proponent of which is diversity so give
time for other companies to launch other
models give time
to Launch Open Source models and to
start to play where a lot of the
research Community brilliant folks such
as yourself start to play with it before
it runs away in in terms of the scale of
impact it has on society my
recommendation would be a little
different it would be let the Google and
the meta Facebook and all of the other
large models make them open make them
transparent make them accessible let
open AI continue to train larger and
larger models let them continue to trade
larger and larger models let let the
world experiment with the diversity of
AI systems rather than sort of fixing
now
and you can't stop progress progress
needs to continue in my view
and what we need is more experimenting
more transparency more openness
rather than oh open AI is ahead of the
curve let's stop it right now until
everybody catches up I I think that's
um doesn't make complete sense to me the
other component is we should yes be
cautious with it and we should like not
give it the nuclear codes
um as we make more and more plugins yes
the system will be capable of more and
more things but right now I think of it
as just an extremely able and capable
assistant that has these emerging
behaviors which are stunning
rather than something that will suddenly
escape the box and and shut down the
world
and the third component is that we
should be taking a little bit more
responsibility for how we use these
systems basically if I take the most
kind human being and I brainwash them I
can get them to do hate speech overnight
that doesn't mean we should stop any
kind of education of all humans we
should stop misusing the power that we
have over these influenceable models so
I think that the people who get it to do
hate speech
they should take responsibility for that
hate speech I think that giving a
powerful car to a bunch of people or
giving a truck or a garbage truck should
not basically say oh we should stop all
garbage trucks until we like because we
can run one and one of them into a crowd
no people have done that and there's
laws and there's like regulations
against
you know running trucks into the crowd
trucks are extremely dangerous we're not
going to stop all trucks until we make
sure that none of them runs into a crowd
no we just have laws in place and we
have mental health in place and we take
responsibility for our actions when we
use these otherwise very beneficial true
tools like garbage trucks four nefarious
uses so in the same way you can't expect
a car to never you know do any damage
when used in especially like
specifically malicious ways and right
now we're basically saying oh well we
should have these super intelligent
system that can do anything but he can't
do that I'm like no it can't do that but
it's up to the human to take
responsibility for not doing that and
when you get it to like spew malicious
like hate speech stuff
you should be responsible
so there's a lot of tricky nuances here
that makes this different because it's
software so you can deploy it at scale
and it can have the same viral impact
that software can so you can create Bots
that are human-like and it can do a lot
of really interesting stuff so the raw
GPT 4 version you can ask
how do I tweet
that I hate they have this in the paper
I remember that I hate Jews in a way
that's not going to get taken down by
Twitter you can literally ask that or
you can ask how do I make a bomb for one
dollar yeah and
if it it's able to generate that
knowledge yeah but at the same time you
can Google the same things it makes it
much more accessible so the scale
becomes interesting because if you can
do all this kind of stuff in a very
accessible way at scale where you can
tweet it
there is the network effects that we
have to start to think about yeah it
fundamentally is the same thing but the
speed of the viral spread of the
information that's already available
might have a different level of effect I
think it's an evolution in your arms
race nature gets better at making mice
and juniors get better making mouse
traps and
um you know as as basically you ask it
hey can how can I evade Twitter
censorship well you know Twitter should
just update it censorship so that you
can catch that as well and so no matter
how fast the development happens the the
defense will just get faster yeah we
just have to be responsible as human
beings and kind to each other
yeah but there's a technical question
can we always
win the race and I suppose there's no
ever guarantee they will win the race we
will never like you know with my wife
we're basically saying hey are we ready
for kids
my answer was I was never ready to
become a professor and yet I became a
professor and I was never ready to be a
dad and then guess what the kid came and
like I became ready so ready or not here
I come but the reality is
we might one day wake up and there's a
challenge overnight that's extremely
difficult for example
we can wake up to the birth
of billions of bots that are human-like
on Twitter and we can't tell the
difference between human and machine
shut them down by how you don't know how
to shut them down
there's a fake Menos
on Twitter that seems to be as real as
the real men knows yeah how do we figure
out which one is real again this is a
problem where an afarious human can
impersonate me and you might have
trouble telling them apart just because
it's an AI it doesn't make it any
different of a problem but the scale you
can achieve this is the scary thing is
the speed and the speed with which you
can achieve it but Twitter has passwords
and Twitter has usernames and if it's
not your username the fake like
experiment is not going to have a
billion followers Etc
uh uh uh
I mean this all of this becomes so both
the hacking of people's accounts first
of all like phishing becomes much easier
that's already a problem it's not like
AI will not change that no no no no AI
makes it much more effective currently
the emails the phishing scams are pretty
dumb like to click on it
you have to be not paying attention but
there you know with with language models
they can be really damn convincing so
what you're saying is that we never had
humans smart enough to make a great scam
and we now have an AI That's smarter
than most humans or all of the humans
well this is the big difference is there
seems to be human level linguistic
capabilities yeah that in fact
superhuman level superhuman level it's
like saying I'm not gonna allow I'm not
gonna allow machines to compute
multiplications of 100 digit numbers
because humans can't do it like no just
do it no but we can't disregard I mean
that's a good point but we can't
disregard the power of language in human
society I mean yes you're right but that
seems like a scary new reality we don't
have answers for yet I remember when
Gary Kasparov was basically saying you
know great you know chess beats you like
chess machines beat humans or chess yeah
you know are you like are people going
to still go to chess tournaments and his
answer was you know well we have cars
that go much faster than humans and yet
we still go to the Olympics to watch
humans run so that's for entertainment
but what about for the spread of
information and news right uh what that
has to do with the pandemic or the
political election or
anything is it it's a scary reality
where there's a lot of convincing Bots
that are human-like telling us I think
that if we want to regulate something it
shouldn't be the training of these
models it should be the utilization of
these models for XYZ activity so
yeah like yes guidelines and guards
should be there but against specific set
of utilizations sure I think simply
saying we're not going to make any more
trucks is not the way
that's what people are a little bit
scared about the idea they're very torn
on the open sourcing yeah the very
people that kind of are proponents of
open sourcing have also spoken out in
this case we want to keep a closed
Source because
there's going to be you know
putting large language models
pre-trained
fine-tune through uh RL with human
feedback putting in the hands of
I don't know terrorist organizations of
a kid in a garage who just wants to have
a bit of fun through trolling
um it's a scary world because again
scale can be achieved and we the the
bottom line is I think where they're
asking six months or sometime is we
don't really know how powerful these
things are it's been just a few days and
they seem to be really damn good I am so
ready to be replaced seriously I'm so
ready like you have no idea how excited
in a positive way I mean in a positive
way where basically all of the mundane
aspects of my job and maybe even my full
job if if it turns out that an AI is
better I find it very discriminative
basically say you can only hire humans
because they're inferior I mean that's
ridiculous
that's discrimination if an AI is better
than me at training students
get me out of the picture just let the
AI train the students I mean please
because like what do I want do I want
jobs for humans or do I want better
outcome for Humanity yeah so the basic
thing is then you start to ask what do I
want for Humanity and what do I want as
an individual and as an individual
you want some basic survival and on top
of that you want Rich fulfilling
experience that's exactly right that's
exactly right and as an individual I
gain a tremendous amount from teaching
at MIT this is like an extremely
fulfilling job I often joke about if I
if I were a billionaire in the stock
market I would pay MIT an exorbitant
amount of money to let me work day in
day out all night with the smartest
people in the world and that's what I
already have so that that's a very
fulfilling experience for me but why
would I deprive those students from a
better advisor if they can have one
take him